Disney has produced dozens of animated classics
over the year, all of them packed with memorable
images.
There are some images, though, that we just
have to linger on longer than others.
Here are some of the most memorable Disney
movie moments that will make you say "Did
I just see what I thought I saw?," pick up
the remote, and hit pause.
Released in 2003, Finding Nemo follows the
story of a little clownfish who is separated
from his father and desperately tries to get
back home.
This Disney/Pixar classic was a massive hit
at the box office and became an instant success
on home video.
Clearly, it was seen by lots and lots of people,
many of them more than once.
"Just keep swimming.
Just keep swimming.
Just keep swimming, swimming, swimming."
That said, it wasn't until many years after
Finding Nemo's release that many viewers noticed
one key detail.
During Nemo's journey, he ends up in the fish
tank at a dentist's office.
When he wakes up in the tank, the camera pans
around the dentist's waiting room, showing
what Nemo can see from his watery vantage
point.
The view shows some toys lying on the floor,
and one of them happens to be a familiar face.
It's Buzz Lightyear, who made his first movie
appearance in Pixar's Toy Story, eight years
earlier.
Pixar is fond of leaving Easter eggs for its
viewers to find, and since this one involves
two of the most popular and heartwarming Disney
films ever made, it's exciting to pause the
movie long enough to spot Buzz Lightyear's
cameo.
Originally released in 1996, The Hunchback
of Notre Dame follows the story of Quasimodo,
a man who is rejected by his people because
of his deformity.
Quasimodo lives in a tower of Notre Dame Cathedral
in Paris, where he serves as the bell-ringer
and spends his days in solitude wishing for
someone to share his life with.
At the beginning of the movie, Quasimodo sings
the song "Out There" from the top of Notre
Dame cathedral.
The camera pans along the street below, and
as it moves, we can see a man shaking out
a piece of fabric.
Look closely, and you'll see it's the magic
flying carpet that Disney fans will recognize
from Aladdin.
If that isn't enough to make you pause, here
are two bonuses: If you look closely enough,
you'll also see Belle from Beauty and the
Beast walking by with a book.
Aladdin is a charming 1992 Disney movie that
follows a street urchin who discovers a genie
in a lamp and has his wishes fulfilled.
But things aren't always as they seem, and
Aladdin must fight an evil sorcerer to save
his love interest Princess Jasmine.
Aladdin was released shortly after another
Disney classic from the same era, Beauty and
the Beast.
Both films were extremely successful, though
Beauty and the Beast might be considered the
greater classic now.
Still, the two movies are connected by more
than the calendar.
In one scene in Aladdin, we see Jasmine's
father, the Sultan, playing with a stack of
toys.
Look closely and you'll see that one of these
toys is actually a model of The Beast from
Beauty and the Beast.
Oscar-winning 1989 Disney classic The Little
Mermaid has one scene that's chock-full of
cameos from characters seen in the studio's
other movies.
There are so many, in fact, that you'll definitely
want to hit pause and count.
During the scene featuring King Triton's entrance,
four other Disney characters are visible:
Mickey Mouse, Goofy, and Donald Duck can be
seen near the bottom left of the screen.
It's a quick cameo, though, since King Triton
is moving so quickly.
If you really want to spot the characters,
you'll have to quickly pause and take a close
look.
Future Disney acquisition Kermit the Frog
is there, too.
You can even spot the Warner Bros. character
Mr. Limpet in The Little Mermaid.
He pops up near the end of the classic musical
number "Under the Sea."
A bit of a lesser-known character, he was
played by Don Knotts, who starred in the 1964
live-action/animated hybrid The Incredible
Mr. Limpet, about a man who is turned into
a fish.
Clearly, there was plenty of room under the
sea for the animators of The Little Mermaid
to show some love to as many characters as
they wanted from Disney and beyond.
The animated Disney film 101 Dalmatians was
first released in 1961, and remains a beloved
classic.
It's the story of an unlikely, and truly massive,
family of dogs that find themselves the target
of an evil, fur-loving woman named Cruella
de Vil.
Because of the adorable heroes in the film,
and Cruella's place as one of Disney's best-loved
villains, fans keep coming back to 101 Dalmatians.
But it turns out the dogs of the title are
far from the only Disney pups present in the
film.
A third of the way through the film, dogs
all across London are participating in the
"twilight bark," barking to each other across
the city to spread the word that the Dalmatians
need help.
In this scene we can see Jock, Bull, Peg,
Lady, and the Tramp, all characters from Disney's
1955 film Lady and the Tramp.
Jock, recognizable by his collar, comes out
of a doghouse.
Bull and Peg, who were in Lady and the Tramp
as dogs in the pound, are sitting in the window
of a pet store.
And finally, after a car goes by, the Tramp
stands on top of a truck and Lady is on the
street.
Moana is a popular 2016 animated musical about
a Polynesian teenager who embarks on a journey
to save her people and find herself.
It's also packed with Easter eggs, including
one that incorporated a Frozen character.
As Moana starts on her journey, she enlists
the help of Maui, a demigod who once owned
a magical hook.
The hook allows Maui to transform into any
animal he wants.
During the middle of the movie, Maui recovers
his hook and uses it to swiftly transform
from animal to animal.
The transformation goes so fast that it's
a blink-and-miss-it type of scene.
If you're really paying attention, though,
you'll see that one of the animals Maui transforms
into is Sven, the lovable reindeer from Frozen.
The scene is fast and definitely requires
a pause button to catch the reindeer, but
the expression on his face is hilarious and
worth going back for a second look.
The movie Big Hero 6, which hit theaters in
2014, is a superhero story about a robotics
genius who lives in a futuristic city.
The boy, Hiro Hamada, puts together a team
of superheroes in his attempt to catch a mysterious
masked villain.
In one scene, Hiro goes to the San Fransokyo
police station to file a report.
Eagle-eyed viewers will notice a "Wanted"
poster hanging on the wall that features none
other than Prince Hans, the villain of Disney's
2013 hit Frozen.
This cameo was fairly easy to spot, since
the police station scene was featured in the
movie's trailer.
But Hans isn't the only Frozen character in
Big Hero 6.
Others found their way into the film, too,
in places that were a little bit harder to
spot.
A ship from Arendelle, the name of the kingdom
in Frozen, and a shot of beloved snowman Olaf
also made it into the movie.
Just keep hitting pause until you catch 'em
all.
The 2001 Pixar hit Monsters, Inc. tells the
tale of the biggest scare factory in the monster
world, a little girl who visits from the human
world, and what happens next.
Oh, and along the way, fellow Pixar favorite
Nemo makes a cameo too.
At one point in the movie, we can see him
hanging on the wall in a bedroom as Sully
and Mike try to get rid of the villainous
Randall.
Later, Boo and hero monster Sully are in her
room together and she shows him a few of her
favorite toys, including a stuffed Nemo.
Here's the real kicker, though: When Monsters,
Inc. was released, Finding Nemo wasn't out
yet.
At the time Monsters, Inc. came out, audiences
probably didn't think anything about the little
clownfish that popped up once or twice.
Many years later, though, diehard fans of
Finding Nemo are fumbling for their remotes
to hit that pause button and smile at the
sight of their favorite fish.
Tangled is a 2010 movie telling the classic
story of Rapunzel with a few fresh twists.
Rapunzel is still the girl who lives locked
away in a tower with her long flowing hair
that can be used as a rope, but she's also
got big dreams.
Rapunzel wants to get away from the tower,
and when a dashing bandit named Flynn shows
up at her window one day, she sees her chance
to begin a new life.
It's the start of an unlikely journey that's
packed with Disney adventure.
There's something else in the film that's
unlikely, too.
At the beginning of the movie in Rapunzel's
tower, one shot shows a spinning wheel behind
the princess.
It's the same spinning wheel from Sleeping
Beauty, the classic 1959 Disney movie.
If you haven't caught this one before, though,
don't feel bad.
Even diehard Disney fans have had to watch
the movie quite a few times to realize it's
the same spinning wheel.
Rapunzel's tower has items that relate to
other Disney princess movies, too.
Use the pause button to look around and you'll
find Snow White's apple, Ariel's seashell,
Belle's rose, and Cinderella's slipper.
WALL-E is a 2008 movie about a lonely little
robot left behind on Earth to collect junk
after the human race abandons the ruined planet
in search of a new home.
At the beginning of the movie, as viewers
are being introduced to WALL-E and his daily
life, the robot comes home after work and
the camera shows several items he's collected.
If you look closely, you might see a familiar
face peeking out from behind a couple of bowling
pins.
It's Rex, the lovable and anxious dinosaur
from the 1995 hit Toy Story and its sequels.
"I just don't think I can take that kind of
rejection!"
The scene is honestly a little sad.
After all, WALL-E is the last robot left on
earth.
The planet is a pretty empty, lonely place.
Did Rex just get thrown away to die alone?
It seems like an injustice to the poor dinosaur.
But at least he has WALL-E. As they say, one
man's trash is another robot's treasure.
Pocahontas, released in 1995, tells the loosely
fact-based story of Native American princess
Pocahontas and English settler Captain John
Smith.
When the two fall in love, Pocahontas's father,
the chief of her tribe, doesn't approve.
To further complicate matters, the other settlers
who arrived with Smith are plotting to steal
gold from the Native Americans.
At the beginning of the movie, there's a scene
during which Pocahontas leaps off of a cliff
in a majestic swan dive, entering the water
with only a small splash.
Although not entirely realistic, her swan
dive is beautiful.
As a kid, it's fun to hit the pause button
and see if you can catch Pocahontas right
in the middle of her leap.
Just don't try to recreate this scene at home.
Disney's Cinderella came out in 1950 and has been delighting audiences of all ages ever
since.
The tale of a girl trying to escape her stepmother's
cruelty and then attending the royal ball
with Prince Charming is a classic.
But Cinderella has a second claim to fame,
too.
The castle featured in the movie is the same
castle that forms the basis for Walt Disney
Pictures' logo.
What started as a simple graphic of white
lines has since become a beautiful three-dimensional
rendering at the beginning of every Disney
film.
You can also visit the castle any time you
want at Walt Disney World, where it serves
as the centerpiece of the Magic Kingdom.
Next time you watch Cinderella, it's worth
hitting the pause button during the scene
when we first see the castle to see how familiar
it seems.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.